so let's take a look at different
categories of effective culture and
teams one of them is is relationships in
bonding connectedness that's not all of
culture there are other things in
culture like Candor and transparency
Innovation and ideation uh
accountability growth and development
collaboration so all we've been
measuring all of these categories for 20
years and the efficacy of teams I'm
gonna pick one bonding the average team
and their score on bonding together in
the in the pre-pandemic world
was 2.8 on a scale of zero to five
and that's answering questions like my
team has my back 2.8
or I deeply care about all members of my
team and all members of my team care
about me that word all really flips it
to being a lower score sure and there's
always that one jerk man
sorry and so that idea of 2.8 now what
happened was during the pandemic when
you were remote
you would imagine that that bonding
score would go down and it did it went
to 2.3 and here's why
because Andrew most CEOs think of
bonding
in a methodology I Call Serendipity
it's the walk down the hallway it's the
coffee room conversation right
but there were teams like Drew Houston
at Dropbox
that said now that we're in remote I
better learn how to do bonding
differently
and so he started engineering practices
that would accelerate the connectedness
of his team while remote so for instance
once a week that team would say to each
other
what is our energy level right now and
why
and so somebody would say oh it's a two
I'm really worried about my mom who's in
assisted living and it's locked down
during covid or whatever or you know I'm
a I'm a one my significant other got a
diagnosis or whatever or or I'm three
this project is draining me that we're
working on at work
now think about this for a second Andrew
in the olden days you might have had
those conversations
serendipitously in small pods yeah you
might have had the water cooler been
like oh I'm worried about my mom but
only in ones or twos
what if Yao you bring a full discussion
in the room where every week you have
that discussion what happens is the
entire empathy of the team goes up
so we curated five of these practices
that yield greater bonding
in a measurable way because we have the
data and if if a team adopted all five
practices the relational score went up
to 4.4 in a remote wow
better than it ever was in a
pre-pandemic world
so
the point is that I'll give you another
example really short one the average
meat talk about Candor transparency
having a full voice that's so important
inclusion the average team meeting of 12
people only have four people think
they're heard
if you use
a collaborative document before the
meeting
you know like a Google doc
and and you have people answering a
question before the meeting
then you come into the meeting everybody
having read each other's answers ready
to collaborate
on the basis of everybody's input
eight people feel that they've been
fully heard
that was that that's like a doubling
that's double yeah yeah I mean and
that's asynchronous collaboration so
what people don't realize is we we
changed where we worked we had meetings
and we moved them to to zoom meetings or
or teams meetings
but what we missed
was the opportunity to actually have uh
to work up and down what we call the
collaborative stack
what do you do in physical meetings what
do you do in remote meetings and what do
you do outside of meetings in
asynchronous collaboration
so this became a really important and
Powerful lesson that we needed to learn
about hybrid work which is you can have
greater candor
by leveraging the collaborative stack
and the tools more effectively you can
get more people involved you can have a
greater degree of inclusion you can have
like for instance instead of even having
12 people in the meeting you could have
30 people opining in this Google doc now
you've got greater inclusion more
diversity of input
and then when you get into the meeting
you land the plane with a smaller number
of people to rustle the ideas forward so
I I just want to make the suggestion to
anybody listening and to CEOs that we're
we're a bit lazy in thinking the only
way to to breed
collaboration Innovation relationships
is old ways of working if you adopt new
ways of working with new tools you can
radically improve the ways we're working
so the the challenge I have for anybody
listening is don't try to make work as
good as it was prior to the pandemic
leverage hybrid work to make it better
than it ever was and it will include
physical work I'm not suggesting you
don't need it you need physical
collaboration for the relational things
for the emotional things for celebration
for fun for gritty issues you want to
wrestle to the ground and look people in
the eye that's where you use physical
collaboration so I hope this was
um you know illustrative a bit to some
deeper Curiosity on how hybrid work can
really make a difference
thank you
foreign